and Jared Kushner came in the equation
his son-in-law I mean just imagine if
Trump's son-in-law was palestin what
what do you think about the Abraham
Accords well the Abraham Accords are a
real reason why this happened why uh
these attacks took place because the
whole point of the Abraham Accords was
to go over the heads of the Palestinians
put that whole issue in the ice box
forever let them stay in their cages or
wherever maybe give them a few crumbs
and then Israel will make peace with the
monarchies who have all the money and
all of the um you know sovereign wealth
funds and Jared Kushner is directly
overseeing that there's going to be more
Trump Towers in Dubai and meanwhile
Trump goes and assassinates kasum solman
second most powerful figure prestigious
figure in Iran who heads the irgc which
has a relationship with the factions in
Gaza as well as Lebanon I mean he was
setting the stage for all this so the
Abraham Accords and the normalization
with Saudi Arabia between Israel and
Saudi Arabia the the alaxa flood
operation declared by Hamas was
explicitly designed to undermine that
like they openly said it then what I I
guess the the issue
is everything leads to chaos everything
leads to conflict well everything leads
back to Jerusalem in in the Middle East
and the Palestinians will not allow
themselves the rest of the region
especially these monarchs who don't
answer to anybody except their own
internal Clan they will not allow
themselves to be ignored what would
happen if the security fencing the
barriers around the Gaza Strip were all
removed and all the people of pal
Palestine were granted free movement
what would happen well it would
certainly reduce the drive to violence
and revenge over time but there would no
longer what what would they be within
what we call Israel and this goes to the
whole logic of Zionism in order to have
a Jewish State you have to have a
demographic majority of Jews within a
certain territory although Israel has no
internationally recognized borders the
US has a border like you all support def
defending the border Israel doesn't
actually have a border it just has areas
that it declares Israel and then it says
we have a majority of Jews we are the
Jewish state so the areas outside aren't
the borders created by all the countries
around it though well Palestinians don't
have a country Gaza is not a country
it's a human Warehouse because they're
not Jews but Jordan and Egypt and
Lebanon they all have borders y yes so
that that's what a democracy while
violently demographically engineering a
demog a majority of a specific ethn
religious group so that would be like
the US saying we are a white Christian
Nation we're not deporting the migrants
because they're not legal Citizens We're
deporting them because they're not white
Christians that is the problem that's
why Gaza is there and has to perpetually
be there but I mean they're having kids
right the population's growing yeah so
it it doesn't I mean Israel could cut
food off and stop population growth they
could do they just cut off electricity
gas and water I mean after Hamas came in
and killed a bunch of civilians and you
know shot up a bunch of you know houses
and stuff I mean so you know I look at
it and I'm like if Hamas perhaps you can
argue that it is a rough Edge scalpel in
their attacks which results in it it
backs fire backfires on them
tremendously uh you know I want to see
peace I don't I don't like the stories
that you know I hear from you about
what's going on in Gaza but all I see
with everything they've just done is
they've exacerbated the problem
10f uh why why would they do this they
have no from their point of view there's
no other diplomatic path to getting out
of the siege and The Siege was becoming
too comfortable for Israel they had
Israel's always going to be in a
comfortable situation as long as the
Palestinians don't do anything firing
Rockets doesn't for what do they gain by
firing Rockets well I mean in in each in
each conflict
the more Rockets I mean this is not my
justification I've been under those
Rockets too it's not pleasant it's not
as bad as being under the Israeli
missiles that I've been under which is
absolutely horrifying with a drone over
your head all night and you wake up and
houses are blown up around you but it's
still scary the point is they get
concessions and it's the only way and
the only time that Israel has ever given
them any concessions whether it's more
work all I hear is Terr works all I hear
you saying is Terrorism works let's
let's look at it from thisp let's make
the other hypothetical State Terror
works as well we're the masters of it
from from the perspective uh from from
your perspective you could make the
argument that Israel lets them fire the
Rockets to justify the the the the
expansion of control over the Gaza Strip
and that you're saying it works maybe
they want it to work they want Hamas to
constantly attack civilians so they can
go to the international stage they can
go to the United States they can go to
foreign countries and say see this is
why we need money and this is why we're
justified in controlling the things that
we control having the iron
I I kind of view it like like look like
right now for the average American who
has no idea about what this conflict is
rooted in all they know is that
civilians were massacred can you tell me
it it is uh go ahead tell me about the
Bal for declaration unless you want to
keep going this is about the Inception
of the idea of the British mandate for
Palestine we talked about last night
basically the end of World War I the
Arabs were fighting with the Ottomans
the the Germans and the austrians and
they were they were winning the war so
the British and the French manipulated
the Arabs and they were like if you
betray the Ottoman Empire we'll give you
this land we call Palestine after the
war so the Arabs were like sweet they
betrayed the Ottomans the French and the
British won the war and then they went
back on their deal with this secret
declaration the balfor Declaration can
you take me from there and talk me
through uh after we we cover where where
you were at uh Tim uh which the gist of
it being to the average person around
the world who doesn't follow this stuff
yeah Hamas just committed a major Act of
Terror killing civilians right well the
the the yeah but that's cuz they're
being propagandized by corporate media
which is telling them this is unprovoked
I mean just look up how many but
provocation is is immaterial I mean like
for for me when I cover this context
isn't material but the reason the reason
that they did it was because otherwise
they're consolidating permanent Siege in
the Gaza Strip and yes it's it's a fact
as you pointed out that Israel initially
supported Hamas actually the mosad
funneled money as Robert Fisk reported
into hamas's coffers and then 1980s
because they wanted to destroy the PLO
which was secular more socialist
oriented and they saw them as the
greater threat Israel allowed Hamas free
movement around the Gaza Strip when
Israel internally controlled the Gaza
Strip but we're ENT we're we're entering
a new era in World Rel in international
relations a multi-polar era where the
United States doesn't matter as much and
so while we this this is kind of a a
bonanza for Israel to be able to show
these images of a music f Festival being
attacked and so on but the United States
doesn't matter as much in the region and
Iran is emerging as a regional power so
I think the calculus on the ground is
changing a little bit and it's moving
more in favor of the Palestinians as
long as and and and I think that is
another factor in why this took place um
on the Bal the balfor Declaration I mean
you're you're talking about the earliest
stages of the colonial Powers handing
over
the land of Palestine to those they saw
as a more powerful force and a lot of it
was motivated actually by anti-Semitism
I mean balfor didn't have kind things to
say about Jews in the UK and so he
thought that if we actually displace our
what he saw as a Jewish Problem onto the
backs of an indigenous population just
get our Jews out of England and put them
there it's going to be a good deal for
us and they'll be our allies eventually
and maybe we can use them to control the
Suez Canal perpetually if we lose
control of it um there uh the the the
the English anti-semites were not the
only anti-semites in history to see
Zionist colonization as a positive thing
uh the largest export market for the
Zionist colonies in 1930s and pre-state
1940s Palestine was Germany and the
Zionist movement the labor Wing the you
know quasi socialist wing actually Inked
a formal deal with Nazi Germany called
the havara agreement the transfer
agreement anyone can look this up it's
on the books and basically what they
were doing was they were exchanging the
property of Jews in Germany for their
bodies and more Jews means we'll start
to move towards a Jewish majority here
and they'll they'll fight the indigenous
people and then the na Nazi Germany was
saying well we'll get their property and
we need their wealth so it was a very
convenient Arrangement um David Ben
guan's number two his name was himar
loov you don't have to worry about the
names but he was actually assassinated
when he bragged about this deal in Tel
Aviv so there's been tons of
collaboration with anti-semites in order
to consolidate the colonization of
Palestine now look at this there's this
carrier battle group that's go sailing
into the region there's so much we can
say about it but what it but here but
one thing it says is that first of all
Palestinians have no sovereignty they
cannot call on anyone to support them
militarily
and I mean Iran Iran's kind of
supporting the military they they can't
come in with a you know their Iranian
fastboats or whatever they they can't
really come in there they can't get in
there thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net